hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today I bring some sad
news which is why I'm not quite as
chipper as I usually would be in my
intros but really I wasn't sure if I
should cover this or not because it's
not the sort of thing my channel usually
tackles a given hunt predominantly
Hunter hunter content tensed feature on
this channel I thought it's somewhat
appropriate to inform anybody who
doesn't already know that very
unfortunately Keiji Fujiwara better
known to many of us as the voice of lei
audio in the 2011 anime passed away on
the 12th of April this year now very
notably this was not the result of the
current global pandemic and it was
instead due to cancer and apparently
Fujiwara had been tackling this issue
seriously ever since mid 2016 when his
talent agency his talent agency that he
founded by the way but it announced that
he would be taking a hiatus to undergo
medical treatment for an unspecified
illness so you know very much following
in the Hunter hunter footsteps there
with the hiatus but he did resume work
in mid 2017 and as far as I'm aware he
had been working very solidly up until
recently and obviously I extend my
deepest sympathy to fujiwara family and
friends at this time but I also did want
to take a brief moment to pay tribute to
how his work has impacted me as many of
you know my hunter hunter initiation was
via the 2011 anime and honestly lair his
voice was one of the things that had me
pretty instantly hooked and invested
into the early days of the series the
hunter exam isn't well you know it's not
the greatest of Arc's let's be honest
but Fujiwara brought such gruff
energetic and even a sympathetic
performance to the character of lei oreo
and it's pretty depressing to think that
if and when the hunt hunt or anime ever
continues which is a big if I will admit
that but if and when that happens that
Fujiwara just won't be a part of it and
this is far from the only impact that
Fujiwara has had on me and millions of
others because if you take a look
through this man CV it is absolutely
absurd and the amount of projects that
he has been involved in just boggles the
mind so for example he was the voice of
RINO and just about every Final Fantasy
7 project including the remake that was
just released but another very formative
role was that of mass use in both
iterations of Full Metal Alchemist being
the original anime and of course
Brotherhood and you know as much as I
have pretty incredibly strong opinions
on both of those series one of the great
constants of quality was the mass use
because fujiwara justice would be Oreo
did a supreme job of turning Hughes into
a gripping personality someone who you
really
that you could not live without and
going back an awfully long way to a
series I was watching in high school
which you know I'm 30 now so that was a
while ago but Fujiwara was also Holland
in Eureka Seven which blew my mind when
I found that out but when I think about
it in retrospect I can very clearly hear
his voice in my mind's delivering
Holland's science interestingly enough
for Japanese specific audiences though
Fujiwara voice was absolutely massive in
the dub scene as he was the actor who
would portray rub it down a genius
characters so for example Fujiwara was
Tony Stark
in the entire Japanese incarnation of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as well as
all of his other characters like
Sherlock Holmes and here's something
really really strange it has no effect
on me I haven't even seen it but I just
thought it was interesting is that
apparently Fujiwara was also the voice
dubbing Cuba Gooding jr. in the People
vs OJ Simpson which essentially means it
alongside the Oreo and Mars Hughes
Fujiwara has also played OJ Simpson that
just goes to show the range of
performative depth that this man had and
back to the realm of games he was also
found favorite axel in various Kingdom
Hearts titles so you know he had
something of a penchant for playing the
cool hotshot style of character and
usually with red hair when it came to
games more recently though Fujiwara was
also cast as ryokogyu in one piece and
if you're in any way familiar with one
piece you'll know this is kind of odd
because this character is never actually
been seen he's appeared once in
silhouette with pieces of dialogue but
he is intended to be a wildly important
character in the future which is
assumedly white oh I went to the trouble
of hiring an actor of fujiwara zouk to
voice those handful of lines that Riku Q
had and once again it's very sad to know
that one piece will need to move forward
with someone else inhabiting the role
but I'm not just gonna sit here in this
stuff all those credits because we will
be here all day
so I guess to summarize this video I
just want to say thank you to Keiji
Fujiwara for his lifetime of work which
I'm 100% certain that you will have come
across in one way or another I'll leave
a link to his credits in the description
below but to end I just want to say that
I can only imagine what those close to
him are going through right now I also
think that this is as good a time as any
to celebrate the life of one of the most
prolific voice actors in the entire
anime in the in fact you know what
forget anime in the entire voice acting
industry so thank you for everything and
rest in peace good sir